we are continuing to take calls let's go
next to our caller from the 3:03 area
code caller from 303 please make your
name and location known and feel free to
jump right into your question I'm Adrian
and from Colorado I've been listening to
your show very long time
great I kind of call it obscure
questions if that's okay
sure go ahead okay what's your opinion
on cerise they're kind of they've got a
bad rap and like I don't know it would
be nice to have someone like I'm not
kind of famous defending us I guess
okay did you say furries is that what
you said yeah okay and correct me if I'm
wrong are furries people that dress as
animals and or what it would define a
furry for me it's not necessary not all
of them dressed up I personally do but
not everyone does and just people who
take interest into like anthropomorphize
animals like you know Zootopia yeah okay
so and is this for it's not just taking
an interest in anthropomorphised animals
but isn't furries sort of the idea of
being sexually attracted to such
anthropomorphize animals it's actually a
really big misconception it's or like
it's just sort of hobby in it I mean I
can't lie oh there's a sexual aspect to
it absurd like there's plenty of people
who take it sexually but generally it's
not a sexual thing and that that sort of
niche was spread by us yes I have to
third a long time ago I didn't see that
one okay so now as far as it comes to
you you you dress up as an animal is
there a particular animal you dress up
as well my son is kind of a cat demon
thing it's a really intricate - I don't
know I bring a lot of joy when I dress
up and it's like I don't have to be
myself and it there would be a lot of
happiness
interesting what led you to choose that
animal um uh I've always loved black
cats and I don't know it just kind of
like kicked me I guess it was a long
creative process a lot of people
personas take months weeks fully
realized well and now for you is this I
know you said it brings you joy and
happiness does it is there is there an
arousal component for this to you know
not me there is and now what about like
I'm a what about the people that you
maybe are dressing up as an animal for
what do you mean like in other words I
can imagine that there might be some
furries who are doing this because it's
sexually arousing to someone else in
their life if that makes sense
yeah they're they're called for suitors
they have specialized to through that
they generally get kicked out of
conventions and stuff for learning those
because conventions a very safe spaces I
mean there are adult oriented like areas
but generally it's like a really
kid-friendly place interesting well
listen 99% of what I know I've learned
in the last three minutes talking to you
so it's hard for me to really formulate
a strong opinion I mean my view is I
guess the same view I have on most
things I don't know much about which is
if people aren't being hurt by
whatever's going on it certainly doesn't
bother me do I find it to be the most
it's certainly not something that would
appeal to me I think I think you're
going to have to send me to do some
investigative investigative reporting on
this topic but yeah I don't know what
animal I would choose maybe a cricket or
a rhinoceros maybe yeah are there like
animals that are more like I would
imagine a cat Adrian is a more common
furry than like a I don't know yeah I do
I it's mostly uh it's mostly canines
like wolves and foxes and dogs and stuff
that's what you'll see generally okay
most famous ones are at least yeah but
there's I mean the people create their
own
teasers is really rampant species it's
called a Dutch nasal dragon I actually
implore you to look it up it's really
cute actually okay listen I mean I'm
pretty libertarian and everything I'm
getting a bit of an odd vibe from this
call and it's making me wonder whether
there is some kind of unusual subculture
here but I'm not against it you know I
don't know do what everyone yeah I mean
we definitely yeah we're definitely like
we know we're weird we know you don't
like act like this is good that's it
like we don't think this isn't like
necessarily I don't know normal things
okay I mean I don't know it's not pretty
anyone it's certainly not arguing anyone
got it okay well good to the extent that
it's not I say with peace and love
address like the the animal you want and
very interesting all right Adrian
appreciate the call very interesting to
get a little bit of insight into the
world of the furries I think once we did
an interview with one of the the
Westboro Baptist Church people and in
their list of stuff that's really bad or
sinful they listed furries for some and
I was barely even aware of that like
that that this call is 99% of my
knowledge of furries when the Westboro
Baptist Church people mentioned it
that's the other 1% that makes up like
my total knowledge of it just sounds
like the Westboro Baptist Church is
going after whatever urged them the most
yet not just what God is upset with
right God is very upset with furries if
you believe them during that interview
all right well that's an interesting
place to stop we will take calls again
we will take a break and then answer
some of your specific questions next